I've got that's near zero how could
there be was the numbers out there how
could there not be lots of them out
there but what what is the possibility
that there are so few that the distances
involved make it so not even said he
couldn't find anybody else and he said
he we already know from the SETI work to
date that there's nobody nearest this is
blasting out the sort of messages that
the movie contact is suggesting when
that's not happening and setting itself
agrees that chief we don't find anybody
in the next 30-40 years this could be
pretty good chance there's nobody close
enough to us that we would ever be able
to either talk to them let alone get out
there and see them
I suspect the chances are that we will
not at least in the next few centuries
perhaps our technology we get to the
point that we can pinpoint not just the
immediate area which is really all that
we're good for now and spotlight the
entire galaxy or perhaps we get good
enough that we can really start looking
at other galaxies and think then we'll
start picking up evidence that there's
other life out there but if you're
talking about places hundreds of
thousands of light-years away there's no
conversation you ever want to have
waited a hundred thousand years to get
your response and then it comes back to
you and says message garbled please
repeat
well it could be a aspect of
communication but it also could be just
another indication that Medea is correct
the life gets going on a planet and then
kills itself off through colossal
blunders friend of mine said well I
shouldn't call it the madea hypothesis
but evolution is more like mr. bean mr.
bean blundering into one situation after
another you know let's hey let's make
oxygen that'll be cool and then
poisoning almost every bit of life
around it or hey let's make
photosynthesis and then reducing carbon
dioxide so much that we go into it with
snowball earth or hey let's make forests
and then reducing co2 even further and
producing a gigantic almost global Ice
Age in the carboniferous so yeah Alice
let's let's do this as mr. bean